we've been talking about Donald Trump's
use of his pardon power as president and
we actually did a discussion a couple
weeks ago I think it was about who
actually deserves to be pardoned Donald
Trump said he was going to allow NFL
football players or something like that
to send a list of suggestions of people
that they want pardoned and we know that
I think it was one of the Kardashians
who convinced Trump to issue a pardon
and we had a conversation about if
you're going to take seriously who
should be pardoned you've got to focus
on nonviolent drug offenders that are
spending time in prison and there's a
lot of other areas that we could say
these are the areas where we should
focus the pardon power of the president
if he's basically taking requests like a
radio DJ right if that's going to be the
approach we learned yesterday that
Donald Trump is pardoning arsonists
terrorists whose occupation of a
National Wildlife Refuge ultimately led
to an armed standoff you might remember
the story from years ago this is the
Hammonds Dwight and Steven who are I
believe a father-son duo not brothers as
incorrectly believed by many people a
father-son duo who were convicted in
2012 of intentionally and maliciously
setting fires on public lands we know
this as arson colloquially the
intentional setting of fires that charge
carried a minimum mandatory minimum
sentence of five years the day before
his retirement the friendly judge in
charge of issuing the sentence said add
that's too stiff we're gonna give the
father-son duo a lighter sentence it was
appealed and eventually in 2015 they did
end up with the mandatory minimum
sentence and the right went crazy about
them getting the mandatory minimum and
we know with the right mandatory
minimums are a core element of
maintaining law and order when it's
brown people caught with pot then
mandatory minimums are just absolutely
necessary but all of a sudden when it's
the anti-government white anarchists who
are holding hostage public lands
mandatory minimums become oppressive and
judges willfully disregard them and now
that's who Donald Trump has pardoned
this is who needs a pardon when we have
this pardon roulette or I don't even
know what you call it I mean it is I
think the
analogy is you call into a music station
and you make a request for a song and
the DJ says somebody asked for it so
I'll play it
Trump basically taking requests for
pardons and this is ultimately who we
get and I would argue Pat even if you
support the president's pardon power
which it exists right how can you how
can you you could say I think it's wrong
but it exists if you want it to be used
responsibly how is this a good use of
pardon power yeah I guess a few of
trumps pardons have been okay like he
pardoned that woman who is sentenced for
decades over a simple drug crime I agree
but then there are others like Dinesh
D'Souza why does he deserve a pardon or
these guys in Oregon just doesn't make
any sense it seems to be that when the
the pardon the pardon is related to I
guess a sentence that is politically
related like the Dinesh D'Souza thing
was okay he did the thing he was accused
of but the only reason he was even
targeted was because he's a right winger
for example or these Hammonds
I mean they I don't even know what the
excuse would be I guess just that
honestly I don't even know like they did
the thing and there's a mandatory
minimum I don't know what the excuses
but that it became very political
because they are right-wingers or
something like that what if it was a
Muslim father-and-son team okay hire two
public lands committed arson do you
think trumpet part of them of course not
and if it was if it was a couple of
black guys who were holding hostage
federal lands and leading to armed
standoffs if it was Muslim immigrants
here in the United States legally from
you know maybe one of the countries of
Donald Trump's travel ban or maybe not
one of those countries maybe a different
country and what Trump is doing by
pardoning nationalists terrorists is
sending a signal that you can do this
stuff and this isn't just an ideology
that we need to vote out in November we
need to demolish this from the ground up
because it's a toxic malignancy on our
society and it's coming from the Oval
Office
it is being de facto implicitly
supported by the choice to pardon these
individuals that's klemming coming
directly from Trump you have violent
arsonists being pardoned while
nonviolent drug offenders continue to
sit in prison and it's made even worse
by the fact that these were crimes on
federal land right
it would be bad enough if these were
violent crimes against private people
with no connection to the government
right
the government is pardoning individuals
for their crimes against federal land
and you know what this is part of this
is part of the attack on government this
is part of the idea of small government
and strangling government and government
being the bad guy
although simultaneously Donald Trump is
part of the government that is doing all
these horrible things this is part of
that ideology and I don't know what the
the path forward is other than voting
them out the the pardon power of the
president is pretty absolute as we've
learned including in the discussions
about whether he could pardon himself I
don't know that there's much resource
recourse here other than just voting
them out discuss this with us on our
david pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t quick
break back after this today's program
brought to you in part by Blink accom
slash Pakman Linkous is a great service
that i use all the time what they do is
they take thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink as' I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS Jobs and there is a great new book BS
Jobs by David Graeber which I listened
to on bling cos they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you'd like
it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK ist
dot-com /pa que mas